did you ever feel like when you're being
bullied that she wanted to take your own
life Virginia and I met in middle school
our relationship was basically she was
someone that I picked on I was a bully
to Virginia
so my first encounter with bullying I
guess with her probably was around fifth
grade I think I said nasty things about
how much she weighed the kids I went to
school with in elementary and middle
school we all lived in the same
neighborhood so I wouldn't come outside
most of the time because most of the
kids that you know kind of were mean to
me lived in my neighborhood I can't say
that I really really had any friends
back then I was I was a bit underweight
I had my classes I went through seven
years of orthodontic work I was picked
on for that and so I would project it
onto her for being overweight do you
have any questions for Natasha
[Music]
I guess them the main question would
just be why now as selfish as it sounds
I don't want to feel guilty for
something that my childhood self was
doing thank you what do you what do you
remember about me from grade school you
always are so bubbly I remember dad oh
no what do you what do you remember
about me I remember more of what I said
about you and I don't I know a lot of
love the I guess the words the harsh
words were more about my appearance I
remember picking on you about Zoe
nobody noticed the shift but my
grandmother passed away when I was in
middle school and she needs to take
medicine for cancer and it it made her
gain a lot of weight because she wasn't
really worried about you know how big
she was I kind of start worrying about
how big I got how people just kept
bothering me and I think the major
question was just like why me I felt
like I was always very nice to you and
very nice to everybody else so it just
it bothered me because if it's just like
what did I ever do to you all for me to
even you know be subjected to that I was
underweight I was I'm taking medicine to
be a healthy weight and so I was
projecting that on you and I don't think
that I even had any problem with the way
you looked or your weight at all why
don't you stop I was being bullied and
so
I knew it was wrong you know I didn't
want that done Timmy but yet I turned
around and was doing it to other people
I don't know I didn't really need to
it's funny you you thought that I was
very bubbly and friendly because I was
wearing this like a staff I wear it
better now and more honest about my
feelings but I was definitely wearing
off the side right I go home cry about
it come back and be all like anything
they need and then I pick on people that
I felt like weren't gonna pick back with
me right it's not it's not you I mean it
was it wasn't just you so I'm not gonna
sit here and give you all of that did
you ever feel like we you're Billy being
bullied that she wanted to take your own
life
[Music]
it was owned definitely I thought this
is probably the first time I've ever
said it out loud
well probably second thought my mother
said out loud but yeah I can't say that
I had thought about it um there's such a
sad thing to think about me you said you
thought about this here yes just short
answer yes I was insecure for a long
time about my weight about my parents
about the way I dress it took a long
time for me to kind of like me for the
warm I'm listening to you the more I
feel like yeah we had a lot and come in
it'd take a lot for me to really hate
you I didn't feel like I hated you then
I don't feel like I hate you now and it
took a long time for me to say even
though I haven't said it to to you that
I forgive you guys for that it was a it
was a lot to deal with
it's okay it was a lot to do it and I
just wanted to move on from it I've
never actually had something like that
happen to me before I definitely did not
expect for Virginia and I to have so
much in common
it felt good just the kind of clothes
sort of champ down our life that was
like pretty sucky let me oh my god yeah
I was gonna get away cuz I don't kiss
[Music]